solo a Star Wars story was pitched to
audiences as a look into the life and
times of Han Solo but Star Wars fans got
a lot more of the history of the world
around Han than they might have been
expecting and nothing was more
unexpected than the return of Darth Maul
while mauls appearance didn't have much
of an effect on solo story it suggests
huge implications for the way the Star
Wars saga will unfold down the line
let's break down what Darth Maul's
appearance in solo means for the future
of Star Wars criminal circle the most
direct plot consequence of Darth Maul's
return has everything to do with his new
day job running a criminal enterprise in
solo mall is the shadowy leader of the
crime syndicate crimson dawn with dryden
boss and kira near the top of the
organization's hierarchy other than
crimson dawn the galaxy plays hosts to
groups like the Mandalorian Death Watch
the Hutt clan and the pike syndicate
with the pikes facilitating the
smuggling of spice out of Kessel the
other two organizations have ties to
very familiar Star Wars characters the
Mandalorian Boba Fett and Jabba the Hutt
both of whom eventually end up having
dealings with Han Solo considering that
a Boba Fett movie is in the making and a
Java appearance is clearly set up by the
end of solo the intersecting crime
syndicates appear to be an ideal way to
connect the different Star Wars stories
back into a larger world with an
underground criminal web pulling the
sprawl together everything is connected
for fans who only watch the movies Darth
Maul has long been out of the picture
obi-wan Kenobi cut him in half and then
both pieces of him fell into the unknown
depths of Naboo but as his appearance in
solo indicates the movies aren't all
that matters anymore
while tons of Star Wars lower outside of
the main series of films was jettisoned
after Disney purchased Lucasfilm Darth
Maul remained in the animated canonical
Clone Wars he survived his thrashing at
the hands of obi-wan Kenobi thanks to
the force of the dark side Maul ended up
being transported to a trash planet
where he passed the time by constructing
himself a set of robot spider legs maul
went on to become a pivotal character in
these Star Wars the Clone Wars animated
TV series as well as it's follow-up Star
Wars rebels while those shows have been
canonical as far as Disney is concerned
few characters who have spent so
much time on the small screen have
returned to the big one until now the
fact that malls story is now being
folded back into the movies has huge
implications for the rest of the Star
Wars Canon suddenly all the characters
from Disney's expanded universe feel
like fair game to get called up to the
movies major leagues and that's never
really been a possibility before versus
ob1 malls appearance in solo won't
necessarily be explored in a solo sequel
after all han Solo and Darth Maul aren't
known for their dealings together malls
real nemesis of course is the man who
chopped him up in the first place
obi-wan Kenobi molls quest for vengeance
against the self-exile Jedi dominated
his story in Star Wars rebels which
canonically takes place several years
after the events of solo a Star Wars
story the quest for revenge comes to
fruition in the Star Wars rebels episode
twin sons with maul finally tracking
down obi-wan on Tatooine their duel
doesn't end well for mall with obi-wan
dispatching him almost effortlessly but
even though we know where mauls story
ends up there's still a lot of story
left to tell with years worth of gaps to
fill with a potential obi-wan movie on
the horizon could mall story continue in
that film rumors indicate that the
obi-wan movie is currently in
pre-production scheduled to be filmed
after episode 9 wraps it's all subject
to change but it feels compelling crime
lord or not maul doesn't really belong
in a solo sequel not as much as Jabba
and his people for the bounty hunter
Boba Fett but an Obi one movie is a
perfect fit and maybe where we can
expect Maul story to properly pick up
next magical new worlds at the
conclusion of solo Maul summons Kira to
come and meet with him on his home
planet of Dathomir a world previously
unseen on the big screen Death Aamir has
played host to a number of malevolent
force users not Jedi not sip but
something in between
along with his brother Savage Opress
Maul was raised on the planet by a
society called the Nightsisters
force-sensitive witches who used death
Amir's strange energies to wield potent
magic the existence of wizardry on the
fringes of the force is an aspect of
Star Wars that's remained relatively
unexplored in the movies where any
mystic character has
typically either been a Jedi or Sith but
in the expanded universe the force is
more like a spectrum for one thing
there's the existence of gray Jedi who
draw from both the light and dark sides
of the force
additionally the force sensitive sure it
in rogue one also broadened our
understanding of how the forest
manifests Bald's story could further
that developing understanding in the
movies his homeworld would be a perfect
venue for expanding star wars
presentation of the mystical adding some
mystery back to the force by
demonstrating that it's not always as
simple as a light side and the dark
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our youtube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know you love to
[Music]